earlier this week broncos tackle juwan
james suffered an achilles tendon tear
while working out away from the facility
working out to get ready for football
season but
it sets the stage for james to not be
paid players like patrick mahomes
confused by the fact that a team could
take away a guy's money
for working out in the off season that
has sparked
a couple of memos one by the nfl
to all teams reminding them of something
they already knew about
if a player gets injured away from work
he's not covered there are certain
protections a player has
when he shows up at the facility and
suffers an injury there that he doesn't
have
when he suffers an injury away from the
facility even if he is
working out to get ready for football
season that memo
to the teams was viewed as a gratuitous
middle finger to the union because the
teams already knew this was a
an effort to to get the players
attention and so yesterday
peter the nfl pa responded with a memo
of its own
to all players calling the memo by the
league
gutless and a scare tactic aimed at
getting players to show up
because the point is hey if you're
working out on your own and you get
injured you're going to lose a lot of
money
you better come to work the problem is
if you're working out on your own and
you get injured you're going to lose a
lot of money
you probably should go to work that's
that's that's the flaw in the nflpa's
position
juwan james is the example of what
happens and
i think they may have some argument to
make that because james was
following a workout regimen given to him
by the team when he got injured away
from work that maybe
maybe at the end of a three-year fight
you win that i don't think he will
you want to avoid the fight altogether
you do that workout regiment the team
gave you
at the team's building then you never
have to go down that path you never
have that money in doubt so it's
unfortunate that it's come to this for
juwan james
and i think every player needs to ask
himself do i want to put myself at risk
my family at risk my money at risk my
future at risk by working out away from
the facility if i get an injury
but the bigger reality is right or wrong
this is becoming a very real pressure
point peter for the league in the union
you know mike um i had a club official
this week call me and say what's your
stance on this uh on this workout thing
with the union
and i said you know i don't really care
about voluntary workouts
i i you know i really don't i don't
think that voluntary workout should mean
they're voluntary but they're really
mandatory however
i don't like when uh when the union says
to players
don't go well put yourself in the
position
let's say of a minimum salary guy let's
say a guy who's
working to make a team you know he's an
undrafted free agent
and he wants to do everything in his
power to make the team
so he starts going to these workouts at
the club facility
and you know he he basically gets to
know
his teammates he's he he basically is
getting ready to hit the ground running
once training camp begins how is it in
that player's best interest
who's one of your union members how is
it in his best interest
to not show up until the mandatory mini
camp
in or or they or the mandatory rookie
mini camp
and then don't show up at all and after
that until training camp
i don't i don't understand that and the
other part of it
you know as this as this person told me
he said listen
a guy comes in here he works out in
state-of-the-art facilities
he gets lunch and breakfast
you know with with perfect food you know
with dietitians and
and and all that and if he wants to
if he chooses to he can duck into a room
and watch some tape
now he doesn't have to but he could if
he wanted to i
understand that the union says all that
stuff
is what makes this verge on the
mandatory
because if guys who don't do it feel
like they're getting left behind
but if they thought this was such a big
deal then they should have made it a
bigger deal in the negotiations
when they did the new contract uh with
the
with the league last year and they
didn't make it
a big deal with the with it with the
league last year
they got some concessions on off-season
workouts but
they did not get the concession that
says
hey we're gonna encourage our guys to
not
show up for these workouts that can help
you make the team
the only way to make that happen is to
reduce or eliminate the workouts which
is what some veteran players want and as
it relates to the rookies there was a
conference call earlier this week with
agents who represent the rookies and the
rookies if they wanted to participate
most most just don't most don't care
most don't pay attention they'll listen
to their agents
but there was some pushback from the
agents because they want the rookies to
not show up
for anything but the mandatory mini camp
the rookie mini camp isn't mandatory
they don't want it to show up for
anything and i was talking to a coach
about it this week
i mean number one these guys get free
lodging
as they're making the transition to
their new city they put them up in a
hotel
during the off season program rookie
mini camp and beyond they got six seven
weeks
where they can be looking for an
apartment looking for a house while they
have a place to stay and they're not
paying for it and they get their food
and they're able to get acquainted with
teammates and coaches and facilities and
where you're going to be and what it
looks like and how it feels instead of
just being thrown into it cold
for the mandatory mini camp and then
training camp and you know
sims and i went through this yesterday
peter and i talked to a coach about this
as well
for rookies right the dividing line
between the guys who can get away with
not showing up
and the guys who can't and my best guess
is
after round two you better be there
because if you're around three good luck
getting on the field this year if you
piss off your coach by not showing up
for the workouts round four five six
seven you're a danger of being cut
when the roster goes from 90 to 53. and
the undrafted guys
an undrafted guy gonna exercise his
right
to not show up for the offseason program
okay fine
don't even bother to unpack your bags if
you're an undrafted guy and you're not
gonna
bother to show up to begin the
competition to make the very steep climb
from 90th guy on the roster to 53rd guy
on the roster
that's why i think it's easy for the
veterans to say don't show up
to everybody and like those agents and i
didn't i didn't know what you just said
that the agents were
were challenging this uh but look if
you're an agent and you're the agent of
a dumb
of a of an undrafted free agent from
morehead state that guy all he cares
about is making the team
and to me it's unfair to tell that guy
he cannot show up on campus until june
10th
it's just it's not it's not fair just
isn't fair
and so it's the same thing mike remember
when we had this discussion
about voting for the cba
and i made the point that the vote was
1019
to 959 and
in essence it was the vote it was it was
two players
per locker room the average vote
per team was 32 to 30.
32 in favor of the cba
30 against we can guess
what all of that was but i would
certainly guess that an
awful lot of the 32 who approved it
were the lower salaried guys okay and so
that's what this reminds me of it's a
battle between
the you know the millionaires and the
have-nots
and that's how this seems to me but i
simply don't understand
when you did not win this right
in you know and and it isn't a right
because all it is is a voluntary workout
but
i don't think that it's a good idea for
the union to be telling guys
don't go it's just it doesn't help
all of your members because the members
have so many
diverse and conflicting interests and
ultimately it is a competition among 90
union brothers for 53 roster spots
and and that in and of itself makes it
different from the normal union where
everyone truly is banded together
because everyone in the union
has a job and will keep a job unless
they engage in the kind of misconduct
necessary to get them fired hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports